voiçi fabrice sans domicile fixe depuis
là je te présente mes loulous qui dit
qui la maman
malachite et kemal mais se retrouver
sans domicile fixe à rapport à ma
séparation j'étais sûr sens j'étais
propriétaire j'étais à mon compte
ensuite aller partent avec son meilleur
ami ben du coup je préférais partir quoi
je vais pas quand mais chaque fois je le
sors toi la rue et c'est encore des
jacquots ce jack ou cliquer avec les
chefs valeurs sont les chiens est encore
plus compliquée nouveau moralement poids
et non parce que qu'on ait ce sont les
chiens
prenez un commande comme qu'on peut dire
ça c'est simple je t'ai déjà le système
il ne rejette plus des fois les gens qui
nous rejette des forces
on y voit en agressivité mais des fois
il ya trois parce que déjà ils nous
prennent de haut il y aura baisse points
[Musique]
les chiens c'est comment dire ça c'est
mes enfants quoi c'est ma famille quoi
ses amis
pas plus fidèles quoi ya aura jamais
plus fidèle que mes chiens ben ça ne
change la vie parce que de fait on a on
reçoit de l'amour et on leur en donne
poids et ça c'est super important que
les humains qui nous donne pas quoi
malheureusement malheureusement et au
mois jeudi trois fois plus d'amour à
donner trois fois plus d'amour à
recevoir les fâcheuses beaucoup au
niveau de même la relation des gens quoi
dit qu'il ya des animaux il ya une
communication plus et qu'il n'ya pas con
à la rue sans les animaux que je trouve
les gens sont beaucoup plus généreux
qu'on a les chiens regardez la preuve il
vient de ramener des croquettes que tout
seul il ne ramène pas de changer tu as
rien du tout quoi
[Musique]
mais chez elle passe avant tout même si
moi je mangeais pas mais mes chiens
manger quand même donc aujourd'hui la
presse j'ai pas fait beaucoup lamouchi
basse était heureux c'était en priorité
ce matin que je suis arrivé quoi
[Musique]
mais on attend pour traverser la emma la
quitte à gauche
assis là assis là je la gamelle plein
chercher les croquettes pour les loulous
fit d'ailleurs regarder le livre y aller
tout seul déjà allés merci
[Musique]
hague avait déjà au niveau des
croquettes
déjà au niveau budget je le dis clair et
net et qu'après un niveau relations au
niveau relation c'est nickel un petit
concombre en fait ouais ouais parce
qu'en fait c'est toujours les mêmes qui
viennent
dans un premier temps les gens quand on
les rencontre ils ont tendance à se
priver au profit de leur animal et donc
c'est ce qui nous encourage à vouloir
les aider
l'idée de passer par l'animal pour
atteindre l'humain j'ai trouvé cette
idée vraiment génial
[Musique]
dix mois